So we run the model and reduced much
of the unnecessary predictor variables.
Now let's test how this model
performs with an independent sample.
This will be the validation data set.
To do this, Alteryx has a great
tool found in the gallery
called the model comparison tool.
This allows users to validate models and
compare models against each other.
Check out the instructor notes on how
to add this to your tool palette.
So what we're going to start with,
is our full built out stepwise model.
I'm now going to bring in that
model comparison tool, and
show you how to use it.
In the m input side, we throw in the
model object that we want to validate.
So the model object
from the stepwise tool,
goes into this m model comparison input.
The other side is the d side, this is
going to be our validation data set.
So I'm going to grab the v from
the create samples tool and
plug that into the model
comparison tool.
Now the only thing we need to configure
with this model comparison tool is,
what is the positive target class?
Meaning, do we want yeses or
nos to be positive association or
trues or falses or ones and zeros?
And just know I'm going to use yeses for
this result.
As you can see,
we have three different outputs, but
I'm only going to look at this
R output which is the report.
So there's many different results that
come outside of this model comparison
report.
The first thing is the fit and
error measures.
This tells us the overall accuracy
as well as the accuracy of predicting
nos as compared to predicting yeses, and
some other different variables that we
don't really need to go into too much,
yet their definitions
are found right below.
As we can see, the validation data set
was predicted quite well by this model,
and overall accuracy was at 91%.
The nos were predicted
quite high at 92%, yet
the yeses were a little bit tougher to
predict, it says, at only 83% accuracy.
This next result is the confusion
matrix which shows us of the nos,
how many were actually predicted
correctly as compared to the yeses.
As you can see, we have 504 records that
were predicted no that were actually no.
Yet we had 45 records that were
predicted no that were actually yeses.
This result shows a pretty
good representation
of where biases may occur.
Do we have way more nos that
were predicted yeses, or
way more yeses that were predicted nos?
And lastly, we have some different
diagnostic plots at the bottom that
we'll go more into later.
But judging based off of just this
confusion matrix and the fit and
error measures,
I think this model is quite strong.
But before we get ahead of ourselves,
I'm going to test this model out against
our other models that we're
going to create next.